Nick's favorite. It's catchy. Yo, so
>> dude. There's no way it's as transparent as this, right?
There's no shot. It's this transparent that it's like, yeah,
she was like a small streamer who entered this contest and I
was like, hey, I can make you a big streamer. What's the path
to you becoming a big streamer? My dick. My my my dick is the
path to becoming a massive streamer.
So, I think there's two videos here. >> Any end in sight
for the divorce? >> Let's fire them up. NMP Lol and Molina
divorce goes nuclear from a day ago. And then Henry Brazilian
actually produced a follow-up video. All right, >> after
my NMP and Melena video, >> this is NMP lol and Melena
fake divorce docs drama. So apparently people are accusing him
of editing the documents.
Yeah.
Like editing the documents about their divorce. I don't see why
they would accuse him of that. He's produced like he's published
like so many of these things. I don't really believe that he
would have actually done it, but
hey,
there's some there's some o tweets around it, you know.
We'll see.
I suspect this is like OTK people. No, no, no, no, no. They're
they're saying Henry would have edited these documents. I suspect
OTK people are coming in and going, "Oh, you you you [__]
this up. You you edited these documents. You suck." I I suspect
so. Okay. I don't know for sure. I don't know for sure. Okay.
Let's just hop right into it. To be honest, I I don't have a
lot to add to this in the preamble. So, I think the best thing
to do would just to be jump right into it. All right. Here we
go. Any end in sight for the divorce?
I mean,
uh, you know, I'm not going to lie. >> I don't think I've
ever spent more money on something and nothing's gotten done
in my life. I I really think lawyers
did he think where did he think all the jokes came from? I love
when there's like an entire cultural meme around how inefficient
ineffective something is and then people deal with it and they're
like, "Wow, this thing was really ineffective and and expensive
and it was terrible just the whole time." I'm really shocked
that literally everybody who's ever gone through this has said
the same thing.
What? No, this is literally everybody has the same opinion on
this.
just on on both sides just file motions so they continue to get
paid cuz the nothing ever happens. Nothing ever changes.
>> It's just been >> nothing ever happens. Chud strikes
again except this time it's in NMP L's divorce >> It's
just I I think I honestly I should have been a [__]
lawyer. It is the biggest scam
ever. Like ever. Yeah. you know, we're going to file this motion
that's going to do this, but it gives them, you know,
I just I have a suggestion for him. Did he think about like making
sure her life was taken care of when he immediately got divorced
or did he cut her off financially like immediately and make her
have to file a whole bunch of stuff legally? Cuz if memory serves,
he basically had control of like all the bank accounts, all of
their income, and she was like locked out of everything. Now,
I don't know if that was just she wasn't living with him and
she didn't she basically just got money from him on the side.
But like what he should have done the second she was like cutting
off, he should have said, "Here's a way for you to remain financially
independent like right now while we figure this out." That would
have gone a million miles. But you know what he probably did
was he probably got really act mad. He probably cut everything
off, pretended he didn't know that she wouldn't have money and
then got really shocked when she was like like it's really easy
to know what you should be doing in a divorce. Everybody knows
there's just a lot of emotions there. There's a lot of judgment
there regardless of who initiated or whatever. And yeah, NMP
just from what I remember, those first couple documents were
not favorable to him. Three days to reply, but the motion's completely
[__] irrelevant. Oh my god, dude.
>> Here's the bill for $9,000. Man, we talked for 7 minutes.
The reason Nick's divorce is so polarizing is because he started
out claiming there was no drama or fighting. >> But I can
say there's no like fighting or anything. So if anyone's looking
for fighting or drama, it's not going to it's not there. >> Only
for Melena to accuse him of financial abuse, which in some of
the newest filings, she lays out some of her proof. Combine that
with him coming clean stating he hasn't talked to her in over
a year. It's safe to say no one gaslights their audience more.
>> Well, face to face. Come on, Henry. Face to face, Henry.
Face to face is way different than right. It's criminal IMO.
I've not talked to Molina face to face in almost a year yet.
Texas says she's entitled to my earnings. Wild. No, it's not
wild. You have to file divorce proceedings really quickly. That
was it. Who filed the divorce proceedings, by the way, cuz I
could have sworn it was Melena? Was it Nick or was it Melena?
Like, who is the person who filed?
Cuz to me, I thought I thought for sure it was Molina. Seemed
like Nick was just trying to hope the problem would go
So that's that's entirely on him. Hey, if if you're not talking
to her, you she said like we're separated. You have to understand
you should go talk to Olivier immediately to say, hey, what's
going on here? and they'll tell you, "Oh, actually, if she's
separating from you, you probably need to file for divorce because
otherwise everything you earn while you're not with her, if she
earned half of that or if she owns half of that business, if
she was at there at the start of it, you'll be [__]
You'll be really [__] buddy." So, Crazy NP is supposed
to be one of the more responsible streamers. I mean, on a sliding
scale of responsibility, it seems like we've got between a six-month-old
and like a four-year-old. And like, the most mature streamers
are basically equivalent emotionally to a four-year-old. seems
seems to be the way this all goes most of the time. >> Then
Nick, unless it's Hassan trying to convince people, we didn't
see him shot >> America, Kaa, please justing go just >> Going
back to the divorce proceedings, Molina also accused Nick of
cheating on her while she was tending to her mom. pointed out
how Nick >> Oh, real quick as we're starting this off at
the off the bat, guys. Okay, there is a blastoff tweet pinned
in both chats. I need you guys to like that blastoff tweet, retweet
that blastoff tweet, comment under the blastoff tweet with links
to the Twitch stream, the kickstream. I appreciate all of your
support, guys. That's a big way you can support. If you can't
donate monetarily, everyone can have a Twitter account. Everyone
can like and retweet the blastoff tweet helps us get out there
to more people. Helps the the stream get more eyes on it. Okay,
appreciate you guys. Love you. Let's continue on with the video
>> is spending all their money on it's Kachchi. In the
new court documents, she finally names Norah the Explorer and
Kochi as having a romantic relationship with Nick, but we will
get into that >> There is no legal separation in Texas.
So, if you have moved on before that final divorce decree has
been signed, that is considered adultery. >> This is likely
why Nick and Kachi are trolling about them having a friendship
but keep getting caught slipping. >> I'm glad you guys
are happy and in love. Yeah, we're we're just friends. >> Excuse
me. >> I mean like like like cuz friends can cuz cuz friends
can be in love with each other. You >> sure about that?
>> Friend friend. >> Which is so true cuz
>> sure Nick denied cheating on Molina and how could he?
Because Mr. Arthur was all over his at TwitchCon. Nick cheating
is going to have a bigger financial impact in his divorce. She
was going to file a motion for Nick to buy her a car and give
her access to their bank accounts along with requesting lawyer
fees and uh financial support. While Nick was trying to seal
the case like your favorite streamer's RP wife, Molina agreed
to temporarily seal it, but where there's a will, there's a way.
Maybe Nick doesn't want to you to know about Yo, why is Henry
dick shaming? Hold on. Why is Why is Henry dick shaming baby
Nick? That's rude, man. Was there something in the documents
about this? I didn't see that in the documents, Henry. I come
here for the documents and not the sass. What the >> You
seal it, but where there's a will, there's a way. Maybe Nick
doesn't want to you to know about how much money he's about to
lose on top of the 7,500 a month in spousal support he is already
paying. Nick already didn't want my 85year-old self to read his
court docs, but here we are. You probably might see all the account
numbers once the case gets unsealed and you guys can go through
my documents cuz I don't know why in the [__] in
God's green earth, you know, uh, divorces our public
So, you have your opportunity soon enough, mother. Or you can
watch an illiterate man, you know, who's 85 try and go through
the documents if you want to do. Nick's Nick hates Henry so much,
dude. Okay, never mind. Henry, the baby Nick comment. I take
it back. Nick started talking [__] first. I was wrong
to to try to say, "Well, reel it in." You You go off, King. Okay.
Nick started talking [__] first. That way, too. It's
>> I'm like, "What is he saying?"
>> Listen, you guys call me an idiot for getting another
another lawyer to explain stuff, but you guys are the same people
that listen to Henry [__] resilient and think he's
telling the
>> Like, you call me the idiot. Like, this is this is just
true. Henry just reads the court documents. He gives like a little
bit of context for when he understands,
right? He's like, "This is my best guess about what this means."
He just reads the documents, man. Look at the mirror. >> Nick
divorce is about to get more expensive because Molina is officially
asking for more than half. And I suspect Teto knew this because
he said this in the clip. >> I'm going to say a hot take.
I think Molina treated Nick like I do. I I am genuinely someone
in the side of I >> Oh, wait. Wait. When was this from?
When was this from Hold on. Was this before or after
Pinky Chu ended up at that OTK party? That would be my question.
What was that in July of this year? I think. Was it before or
after that where Tee was like, "Oh, Molina treated him really
badly." I want to I want to know cuz I have a feeling Teeone
switched up once Nick invited his uh former only his former girlfriend,
the only fans model, to the OTK event. All right. >> I
think Nick was actually too good for Melena. I think Melena was
a vile, vile, bitter, cruel, disgusting person. I'
>> example, literally nobody says that. I've I've literally
never heard that from anyone.
I've not heard that from I don't know if I've heard that from
NMP.
What? What? This is just This is just a take entirely fueled
by misogyny and
I just Yeah. Like it's just like Jesus.
Like I've I've only ever heard that Molina is like a a nice person
and most people can't believe Nick treated her that way.
Yeah. I' not that she couldn't do some bad things or something,
but that's like so outside of what I've ever heard about Molina.
It's very weird for Tech to have that opinion. Also not weird
because it's Techone. >> I've never had anybody worse to
me than Melena. Um because she's very pro woman. >> Yeah.
No, I mean I think NMBB just lost.
>> Dude, it's entirely based off of probably Tetown did
some creepy weird and Molina didn't like him. Molina judged him
for how he was with his girlfriends, with his wife, with women
around him and and that's why Oh, she's just a vile disgusting
woman. Okay, sure, bro. Sure, bro.
Dude, there's no >> I am the conflict resolution god. >> Thank
you. >> Lost a lot of weight and wanted to lock the in
order to secure a girl. That way he would see that Nick can succeed
even without her. And now she's trying to take 70%. Which is
like Jesus. I mean damn. Damn. And it's crazy how the internet
is so against NMP that they actually think she deserves all that
money and Nick doesn't deserve any of
>> Wait. I think they should be entitled to what they contributed.
I think it's never been secret that Melena does a ton of work
for his stream. Like a ton of work for his stream. It's never
been hidden. It's never been secret. It's never been cons like
confusing.
She built that business with him for years and years and years.
She should have a right to a big chunk of it,
right? A lot of that stream for a long time was just them hanging
out in their kitchen talking to people
is a very specific number. And Teone didn't come to that conclusion
just himself. He didn't just guess that. Chances are he spoke
to Nick and Nick totem our >> accusations. based on a response
to an interrogatory, she is demanding a disproportionate share
of the state based on Nick being at fault and you combine that
with his >> Oh, dude, that's brutal for that's brutal for
Nick that like
basically he's pretty pretty easily understandably been
there's there's been infidelity, right? He cheated on on Molina
and then he's continued under like marriage law. he's like continued
to
he's continued in his adultery like repeatedly. So it based on
the fact that it might have been equitable if um if they just
split under normal circumstances,
it would be crazy if the fact that he was like cheating on her
led to a judge going actually you can give her like 60% or 70%
of the assets. That would be insane, wouldn't it?
Like that would be a level of shooting yourself in the foot that
you rarely see. alleged financial abuse. Now, before we go forward,
I want to point out that all these court documents were legally
obtained. As I stated, my channel out is purely to educate people
on divorce. Despite Nick's strong feelings about me or my ability
to read, as someone who has been in his xqc reading as fast as
he could explain the court docs better than Henry's illiterate
ass,
bro, most of us, there's a bunch of us who watch Henry's videos
on the documents. I don't think we ever have any issue with the
way he reads the documents. Why is he saying illiterate? I I've
honestly never seen any issue with Henry reading the documents.
I I don't know where this is even coming from. It's crazy. >> His
shoes while being divorced. Just pay her the money. I get it.
Whatever she's asking for. It may seem like it's
>> If only Nick talked to Henry for advice before he could
have had a better divorce. Yeah. Nick would have been telling
him, "Listen, start burying gold in your backyard. Bury gold
now. Buy gold bars. buried them now. >> But I promise you,
Nick, you will make it back. Instead of giving the lawyers money,
put it in their settlement and save on lawyer fees. Yes, for
the record, Nick is right. I am just a father trying to feed
my daughter. Nick, thank you for making that possible. I really
appreciate that. Nick complains about how the expense of the
divorce is while simultaneously dragging out the divorce process.
Because early on, Molina had to file a motion to compel him to
share mostly financial documents. Motion to compel in family
court is when you are asking the court to basically court order
them to answer their discovery question. >> By the way,
this is like unless Nick wants to dispute this, I assume that
this comes on the back of asking
right? Like he would have asked directly
he would have said something like
or sorry, Melena would have asked directly for like I want a
financial statement or something, right? There's like a there's
a name for it. It's like a proof of financial records. Lawyers
know what it means, especially if they're in family court, right?
It's basically a list of assets that we jointly own. It's not
even a I believe it's like a list of assets that you own that
we're going to combine together to not have things be hidden,
right? It not It's not even jointly owned. It's like give me
the list of assets you have and like when they were procured,
what they've like how much they've cost you, and we're going
to go look through all of this, right? It's basically like you
got to show me what you've got so we know how to split this.
Cuz otherwise if it's just like show me what you think you owe,
then it's like nothing,
right? Then they the person might might say, "Oh, well uh I I
was the streamer. It says NMP lol in the stream. That's me. Maybe
I don't have to show any of my my streaming assets."
So they would have asked first and then then they would have
filed a motion to compel. Which means for some reason Nick or
Nick's lawyers turned that down. They said, "No, no, no. We don't
want to do that." evidence or produc >> or they produced
incomplete evidence. One of the two >> documents that you
had originally asked in the discovery phase, >> but he
was happy to pay her half. Right.
no. Now, before we get into >> half of what? Half of what?
Cuz people don't realize this or people do realize it, but they
cope before until they get into the situation, right?
But like stocks any not just stocks but like any asset you have
that acrru that uh increases in value like that increase in value
is split.
So let's say you
let's say you have like Nvidia stocks right that you bought shortly
after you got married.
All of the brutal one is off in the house. Not for Nick because
if I if memory serves correctly, Nick bought a of Nvidia at like
30 bucks.
I think and like when I say I mean like a
so I think for Nick Nick might be looking at like that Nvidia
stock and be like, "Hey, that was my that was my thing I bought.
Maybe I don't have to maybe I don't have to do anything." No,
no. All of that all of those stocks all the you got there. Yeah,
that goes into the pile. Need to disclose it.
>> All his publicly available core docs. We really should
wish him a happy 10year anniversary as he has been married over
10 years. Remember in Texas you're >> Dude, Henry, let
him live. Henry,
happy 10th anniversary. Nick. Hey, Nick. You said I was illiterate,
but I can read this and I can do math, too. I can do math. Actually,
it looks like it's been about 10 years since you guys got married.
Happy 10th anniversary, Nick. Your divorce isn't final. You're
technically still married. >> You're married or you're
single. Texas does not acknowledge separation dates. If you and
your spouse are no longer together, but y'all are technically
still married. Did you know that half of all the property that
you acquire, half of it belong to your spouse? And of course,
I'm a Texas attorney, so anything that I discuss on this TikTok
only applies to Texas. Now, what a lot of people don't know is
Texas does not recognize legal separation. So, in Texas, you're
either married or you're not. says his marriage crossed the 10-year
line signifying a long-term marriage. That puts me in a position
to secure Oh no, that would be a thing. Yeah, I think that bumps
her up into a different alimony bracket, doesn't it? Oh boy.
Oh boy. Yeah, this is a fun fact. Okay, you ever had like parents
who got divorced or something? Uh there are like brackets basically
for like about the maximum amount they'll give for alimony given
how many years you've been together, right?
So once you get into certain brackets of duration of marriage,
they'll they'll like up how much alimony you can get. That's
so though it's not necessarily it would depend on trust me if
she's getting an uneven split of the assets. If she's getting
more of the assets from their entire marriage than he is, I do
believe she's going to be coming up ahead enough that she probably
won't be getting alimony on top of it. 5,000 per month, the maximum
amount of spousal maintenance that can be awarded. Maximum duration
10 to 20 years up to 5 years of maintenance.
So, okay, 5 years at 5,000 per month. That is a lot. What is
that? 5 * 12 * 5
* 5,000.
Wait, hold on. There's no way that's right. I just did that wrong.
Hold on. Five years at
Five years at 5,000
times 12 for the months. $300,000.
That's pretty crazy.
Yeah. 300K.
20% of his monthly income would be more than 5K. Yeah, but it
looks like there's a cap. Oh, wait.
Why does it say both of these? Wait, why does it say both? Yeah.
Hold on. What? What? Huh?
>> Hold on. I didn't see the second one. 20% of the paying
spouses average gross monthly income.
This must be So, it must be with the cap, right? Maximum amount
disposal. So, it's saying the m This would be a a ceiling. And
then this would be if you don't if 20% of your earnings is less
than 5,000, it would just be the max. Yeah. Obviously.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Whichever is less. Yep. Got it. Got it. easily $3,000 $300,000
in spousal maintenance. But because he already agreed to pay
her 7500 a month, maybe she's in a position to secure 450,000,
but this could offset should she actually be awarded or given
the 70% of the marital estate. >> There's two types of
alimony in Texas. There's temporary alimony and then there's
alimony that would occur. >> Wait, did we see that number
in a document already? Cuz I'd read I'd heard that that was the
number. Did he say that when it when it said she was seeking
an uneven split of the assets? Did it say 70% already? I might
have missed that frame.
We'll keep watching. >> After the divorce process is finalized,
alimony after the divorce is finalized is disfavored in the state
of Texas. What the court would rather do is give the party alimony
a disproportionate share of the community estate. So, I've seen
Nick at at his lowest, at his highest, and legally I I do agree
that Mill is entitled to a certain good amount cuz she was married.
But I don't think that that percentage you're talking about,
which is 50%. I don't think that she deserves that. No offense.
I do think that she did a lot. I know she was like a like a soldier
on the front lines. She was working pretty hard. She deserves
something. But the amount that she's legally entitled to by the
law, probably not, but like I said, it's still legally entitled
to. So, that's a whole different topic. This is based on most
of the court order she filed on September 17th. This was a victory
for Nick because remember he wanted mediation. He requested the
court compel Melena to enter mediation and it was granted. Mediation
officially started September 30th but not sure how it's going
considering he's still not streamed on his main channel. And
according to Melena's filing, she's still locked out of the marital
accounts. Should mediation become a failure, there are some key
dates that Nick had. By the way, I don't know why XQC is saying
that. XQC is in a way different position, right?
Like I think XQC is not understanding cuz he's just he's just
oh, how do you he's having like a trauma response because of
adept, right? That's what's happening with XQC there. He is just
having a pure adept trauma response where he's like Adept wanted
half of my money and she didn't even do she didn't even like
clean my house. She didn't do anything for me. She wanted half
of my money or something, right? even though they're only together
for a year, right? It's a totally different thing.
But with um with Melena, she actually planned content. She planned
content. She was a part of the content on a very consistent basis,
right? She was supporting his stream all the time on an incredibly
like incredibly consistent
>> Jesus, what is this music? I don't like
Whoops. Okay, that's not NMP. Broke P. So, I think XC is yeah,
like I said, having trauma response. Molina is in a totally different
position. She's done so much more than Adept ever did. And realistically,
even if she hadn't, I do believe she's still entitled to like
a roughly equitable split, right? Even if she hadn't, but she
has. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Sweatpants freedom, it's like it literally
doesn't matter. That's what I'm saying is it literally like it
wouldn't matter probably, but she also helped him build that
business a significant amount,
right? And you don't know what their dynamic was.
I wouldn't be shocked if he
Yeah, exactly. Like I wouldn't be shocked if she did a hell of
a lot. I think she was also the editor for a long time. I think
she posted like a lot of the stuff. I think she was his editor
for a long period of time. Anyway, we can continue. has coming
up. If Nick and Melena fail to agree on a bio date, according
to the judge's notes, the two will have a trial date set for
January 12th, 2026.
The date of December 15th, 2025, that was set, which may turn
into a settlement conference since it's already on the books.
Expert opinion reports are due October 31st and may be amended
up until November 12th. This is for evaluations of companies
like OTK and a handful of other businesses they own. Depositions
are to be completed by November 14th. Do not get your hopes up.
Short of them leaking depositions of each other. They will likely
never see the light of day. Lastly, pre-trial
Right. That's the interesting thing is Henry seems to be talking
about this. I don't think that Henry is actually revealing new
information because they did just seal the rest of the documents
in the case. the lawyer, the sorry, the judge in charge of whatever
this this case was said, "Yeah, we're going to seal the rest
of it." Henry snuck one of the docks within like I think an hour
before it was sealed, but that was the I think that was the last
new piece of information we've gotten outside of Nick talking
about it, Tee talking about it, different people talking about
it, >> Evidence, witness list, and exhibits are due December
10th. Before that, there are some other dates. Don't worry about
him commenting on this because both of them are enjoying from
doing so. On July 30th, they both agreed not to make public comments
regarding their ongoing divorce. It's in his best interest to
come to a deal because Nick is on the hook for legal fees. He
already showed out $25,000 to her lawyers. Should mediation be
unsuccessful, Nick will have to pay another 25,000 to her lawyers.
On top of that, Nick has to pay Molina's experts $25,000. All
of this money is to come out of community funds. Any money Molina
receives, Nick will get a credit for when it comes down to the
financial settlement number. >> Nick, I audit attorney
fees. Look up legal audit services if they tell you to pay for
Molina's fees. >> It doesn't work that way. It's all community
estate. >> For example, let's say she ends up collecting
200k in support and legal fees and Nick uses about 100k for his
legal fees. And it turns out the combined community estate is
worth a million dollar. Then Nick would only owe Melena $300,000
to $5 divorce. But I suspect they're worth more than a million
dollars and Melina will walk away with more than 50% anyway as
she has a slam dunk case. Do not worry, we will get to the community
assets listed in the court filings. Continuing to go through
the agree orders, Nick has to re I do wonder cuz I'm I'm still
a little bit behind on the case. I do wonder if
some of the stuff that he talked about in terms of his stock
portfolio and I wonder if that's going to be included in the
community funds or the community assets, right, that have been
described in the court case cuz it wouldn't shock me if the order
to if the the motion to compel a disclosure like a more truthful
disclosure came on the back of him having streams where he talked
about all the stocks he owned and then if he shows up for his
disclosures he's like, "Oh, I don't have any of those stocks
anymore." That seems kind of confusing, right? issue a new credit
card for Melena from their Chase account. Remember, she claimed
she was frozen out of all the accounts. And it looks like she
will have a credit card now. But I saw no mention of her having
access to any other accounts in the court filing. So maybe the
judge just is going to let Nick continue to control all of the
the family accounts and pay her out of it. When it comes to smaller
personal property, uh Nick has to inventory it and Nick has to
grant access to his home or her attorneys in a third-party designate
to inspect personal property, but also for the Pokémon and Magic
the Gathering cards will be categorized and
>> Since the order went into >> Oh no.
Nick's given up half of his holo Charizards. Okay. Half of his
black lotuses, half of his original first edition black lotuses
are going
going over to Melena. Oh no. >> Effect on September 17th.
It's safe to say it happened already.
Oh my god. Oh my god. It's literally It's literally a hollow
Charizard with them. Dude, what? That's crazy.
Not Not first edition. Okay. Not first edition. I don't even
know if this is the original set. It might be a reprint. Who
>> YES. NORA. OH MY GOD. Oh my god. >> Wait, that's
Nora. Oh no, that's Nora.
I thought that was Molina. It was just somebody in a in a sweater.
I didn't realize it's actually Nora. Oh no.
>> All three. I can't believe it, dude. >> How rare
is that? >> I've never SEEN IT. YOU PULL. OH MY GOD. OH
MY GOD. WHAT THE
>> Do you think they reseal? Do you think they go buy the
individual cards and then reseal so they can pop off? I feel
like I feel like this is the easiest content to script to be
honest with you. You just go, you buy like the really rare card,
you put it in the pack, you reseal the pack, then you open and
you just go then you pop off. It's like I I feel like for the
amount like it's not like he went and dug through a ton of
Pokemon card streams where he was constantly opening cards, right?
He just buys like a case, buys like one box, and then finds like
the most expensive car. Seems kind of crazy.
>> It's a real box. I got it from island. I paid 10K for
it. Perfect box. >> Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Oh, he's literally
his chatters are accusing him of faking it. Got him.
Got him. >> Know why it's perfect? Because >> he's
had dud boxes. Okay. Bubble wins. >> I trust you. >> End
of flashback. It would be interesting if he has to give her cards.
She wants or will she want cash instead. >> If you want
to keep your Pokemon cards after a divorce, you either put it
in a prenup or a postnub. And as long as it says you get them
after the divorce, you'll be able to keep them. >> Bro,
there's no way this is enough of a problem that a lawyer made
a YouTube video on it. That's
absolutely wild to me.
That's insane. >> Last part of the orders. It also makes
me feel bad cuz I'm pretty sure I had a set of not first edition,
but like the original set of Pokemon cards complete sitting in
a binder in my house
uh in my like childhood home. I'm pretty sure my cousins grabbed
like a bunch of my cards, including my Charizard. Okay. And I'm
just like I I watch this and I'm like, damn, I bet that would
have been worth a lot.
It would have been worth a >> States. Molina has to set
up a date for her to do the same. I wonder when this happened,
did people in Austin stay hush hush about it? And is this why
Nick chose not to travel with Iskachi to the Philippines? Now
that that's out the way, let's get to see what they own and what
else they will likely have to split. July 9th, Nick's lawyer
accused Molina of not providing documents and answers to their
interrogatory. >> Oh, by the way, I also did this Bruce
Willis. I had like three different Charizards, but I also did
this with one of them. My mom was like, "Hey, I'll take that
to the office and laminate it for you so it doesn't [__]
so it doesn't like get broken ever." And then it was all bubbled
and gross and totally destroyed. Yep. Yep. I I literally did
that with one of the the three or four that I had.
Damn.
Nick accused her of not sharing bank statements specifically
from some Norway account. Not sharing information about any debt
she has. Not outlining her monthly expenses.
>> Oh, hold on. Hold on. We got to I'm I'm missing this
while we talk about >> not providing docu. This was let
me >> happened. Did people in Austin stay hush hush about
it? And is this why Nick chose not to travel with Iskachi to
the Philippines? Now that that's out the way, let's get to see
what they own and what else they will likely have to split. July
9th, Nick's lawyer accused Molina of not providing documents
and answers to their interrogatories. Nick accused her of not
sharing bank statements specifically from some Norway account,
not sharing information about any debt she has, not outlining
her monthly expenses,
not sharing her monthly income compared to her expenses,
not sharing documents pertaining to real estate own. Not documenting
her separate property. He wanted her expert witness >> I
You know what this sounds like to me? It does sound to me
like Nick probably told his lawyers like actually do make this
painful. Do you know what I mean? That like she might have she
might be doing it too, right?
But uh it just feels like they're asking for everything and then
anything that's not provided that they suspect could be or like
very possibly any way possibly could be then they're saying,
"Oh no, provide that as well. provide like literally I bet you
have like a credit card and you didn't provide that thousand
credit card statement to me that like thousand dollars in debt
maybe
I now I'm going to file a motion saying you have to provide that
and the funny thing the not funny this thing is is coming out
of their community funds right it's not like it helps anybody
>> reports which is odd because you know at this point
she has no access to anything to report on also she did not provide
travel records or credit card reports and lastly any priv privilege
logs. This is all standard boilerplate request. You see an all
high >> Hold on. We got bubble wins coming in. He's He's
very He doesn't think Nick's getting a fair shake. Nick purchased
three cars, two houses, and a boat from Molina's parents/b brother.
Does he get half of that back? Uh it depends on if he bought
them as gifts or if he bought them like in a way that goes back
to Melena. He's not getting divorced from her family. He's getting
divorced from
Maybe there's some argument that she could make that consideration
for him, but in terms of the law, I don't know if that I don't
know if you get that back. I really don't
like it depends on what the understandings were.
Yeah, that's the thing is also that's the thing, Kerski. Like
they might have that might just be community stuff, right? He
should just give her 51% of the assets. Well, you have to understand
bubble wins
those those things would have been bought from the shared assets
they had, right? like and and I don't believe because they're
not Melanas, I don't think you can necessarily argue that that's
stuff that like is purely on her side of the balance sheet. You
would really take back the house you bought for your mother-in-law.
That's crazy
I don't know, Matt. They might they might be doing crazy work.
>> Said divorces. In his 106 page filing, Nick would also
share the 20 interrogatories that he asked Molina to answer.
Most of them, >> can't you just hide a bunch of your trusts?
You could try.
You can try x normie, but if there's evidence and the judge decides
like, hey, like
I don't know. I feel like there's forensic auditing that could
happen where if that gets caught, I you might go from just a
problem with your divorce to like like actual criminal problems.
No. What is What is the issue when when you hide wealth like
that and it's proven that you're hiding wealth? What even happens
in a divorce? Cuz I I don't know if you were doing that. I wouldn't
I wouldn't try to hide it in some legal way. I think that would
you over really badly, right? I think you have to hide it in
some other way.
Like a trust or something that doesn't make sense to me. Have
to prove malice. Well, if you hit it in a bunch of trusts like
after you started getting divorced, I feel like that is pretty
easy to prove. Pretty easy to think there's malice there. >> them
all money related. Like, you know, for her to divulge any bank
account she owns. But the big question he really wanted her to
answer was how much of the community property she was asked going
to ask the state to award her and for her to justify why she
wanted such a division. The non-money related questions are if
she believes Nick caused a breakup and if so why. If she committed
committed any act of family violence since January 22, which
is odd cuz it's not like for the whole marriage. If she had been
intimate with anyone besides Nick ever in the marriage. Lastly,
if she thought Nick was intimate with anyone else when we know
she does for the most part. >> Wait, I thought Nick admitted
to this. I thought I thought Nick admitted to this and like people
me'd on him for those
Am I crazy? I was pretty sure he had like actually just admitted
to cheating on her.
She objected almost all requests for productions of documents
citing she didn't have access to them and or them being in Nick's
possession.
uh that they have a joint business. Saying Nick paid for all
of this stuff is to a total misnomer. They have a joint business.
They're paying for those things together. They're married. They
literally have a joint business together. The profits from that
business are used to go towards her mother's
right? That's spending they do.
That's like saying
or depending bubble like if Nick bought a house for his mom,
would you think that Molina is owed like 50% of the money from
that house? As in like okay well now since since that's only
for Nick's mom, he actually has to pay out half of the value
of that house too, even though it's not Nick's property. That
would be that's the question there, >> Which would make
sense for all of the state side accounts considering she alleges
he controlled all the money. Originally, her official answer
was to object to all financial requests, but based on later court
filings, they both have shared all financial records with each
other. But she did leave the door open to supplement her responses,
which is pretty standard. Now, let's get to what Molina believes
they own. When it comes to companies, she believes they own a
stake in OTK, which is understandable because she actually does.
She believes they own a stake in Star Forge Systems, which I
can see that as well as Nick constantly advertised for them.
Most people have forgot about Mad Mushroom, which is an influencer-led
company that is aimed to help smaller game developers launch
their games. According to the website, they have launched five
games with one on the way. I did not know this, but does Nick
and Melena have a stake in Mythic Talent Agency, which is some
of the big >> Almost certainly did have a stake in Mythic.
No. >> Streamers on Twitch like Asmin go. I also found
it funny that when Mythic Talent announced signing Nick, they
also announced signing is Catchy his girlfriend or for legal
purposes that's his friend that happens to be a girl. And we
cannot forget about NMP Productions. I imagine this is the company
that collects all the revenue from YouTube and Twitch. She also
leaves the door open saying that there may be other companies
that she does not know about because she was not provided much
information during the marriage. When it comes to domestic and
international investment, she said she was unable to give a substantive
answer because there's property in Norway that they own. As far
as her having an interest in a trust, she declined owning one,
but brought up the fact that Nick has a trust and she knows absolutely
nothing about it. I think his trust is protected provided he
did not put any marital property in the trust because if he did,
that could make the trust a party to the divorce. trusts and
divorce definitely a source of contention and litigation. First
thing you should know is that anything that you acquire by inheritance
is presumptively your separate property. So the general idea
is your parents have left you a trust, you're not going to have
to divide it in divorce. >> What you like you're an inheritance
guy? >> No. Like a million? >> Oh, okay. How much?
>> No way. >> When it comes to the division of property,
she objects to answering it because it will require her to show
all her proof and she intended to. That's not very confusing
at all. That's like obvious,
right? That also that trust to be clear is from before
they were together at all.
I hope he was 14. Offer it up at trial. However, she is firm
on wanting a disproportionate division of the community assets
based on being Nick's fault and them breaking up along with her
future earning power, future opportunities, and separate property
of the two of them. The answer officially makes it an at fault
divorce with the blame being put on Nick. If a judge can conclude
Nick was at fault, she could be awarded more than half. >> Texas
offers both no fault and fault-based divorces. No fault means
you two can't get along. Something like irreconcilable differences.
Fault-based divorces are an option for you that you can discuss
with a lawyer and would be granted based on grounds like infidelity,
cruelty, perhaps domestic violence. You may use fault in filing
your divorce in a Texas-based case because you'd want to file
for a disproportionate share. And what that means is because
this other person had >> like realistically
this is probably the most compelling case I've heard personally
for disproportionate assets being awarded. We built a very successful
company together. Both of us were like the founders and
only employees there for a very long time. That company is worth
more today than it's ever been worth. And now I'm being forced
out of it because of how this person acted. Because there are
now like we have a this person cheated on me. This person's like
a total piece of [__]
right? She didn't found it. Okay, sorry. They she didn't found
it. She stepped in as the as like somebody who is in a relationship
and had split the work on that channel for a very long period
of time,
right? He was already probably a decently sized streamer when
they got married, right?
She did a hostile takeover.
Are there hostile Can you define a hostile takeover where you
sign like a a marriage certificate with somebody?
You sign the marriage
You don't get a prenup.
Is that a hostile takeover? Are we pretending that Nick is so
that he doesn't understand? Marriage is hostile. You are an actual
[__] Hero is overdosing. Just so you know, marriage
is hostile.
Um, okay. This is uh I hope you understand that under that same
under that same hostile definition you probably believe that
every guy in every situation is actually a
clearly joking I don't think so I don't think he's joking some
sort of wrongdoing or fault in the breakup of the marriage I
should get more of the estate >> when it comes to tangible
property she claims they have a property in Norway six bank accounts
the 2023 Escalade the 2021 Nissan GTR are. She lists all of the
previous business, but note she does not know the legal names.
As far as community debt, they have two credit cards, some leases,
but states discovery is ongoing. Crazy part about this divorce
proceeding is Nick's lawyer asks Melena if she ever spent over
$500, which she objects, but she does name three instances which
were gifts. Person one was given a gift that cost $1,800. Person
two was given a gift that cost 3150. And person three was given
an iPad as a Christmas gift, which all purchases, get this guys,
was approved by Nick. Can you imagine wanting to buy a friend
or a family member a gift and you have to ask your millionaire
husband permission to buy something that costs less than 2K or
an iPad? Like, what the [__] dude? >> Am I
Am I Oh, >> this is a bad look for Nick. This is a very
bad look for Nick. Am I allowed to buy something from here?
>> Yeah. Are you going to carry it around? Why are you
asking me like you don't control the money? Holy [__]
>> Now, Nick did ask if she thought he was at fault, and
she did not hold back, transforming this into a fault-based divorce,
like I said, which will allow her, if granted, to get more than
50% of the community estate. She reiterates that while they traveled
to Spain to care for her mom, who was battling cancer, Nick left
to travel to Amsterdam to attend TwitchCon. When he returned,
she found photos and pictures and messages between him and another
woman in his phone. Considering Molina name drops Nor the Explorer
and is catchy later, do you think that the woman in his phone
was a different woman? She explained that throughout the marriage,
Nick maintained exclusive control over the finances along with
unilateral decision decisionm on spending and distribution of
funds. any of her spending had to be requested and then approved
by >> I feel like at moments like this I just realized
that like
I don't know Sand seems like he should be like the nicest guy
but is there I feel like you just slowly realize every single
person who was in OTK was actually like kind of a piece of and
they all like sort of covered for each other being pieces of
all the time. Like I don't know if there's like a person who
lived in that area or in those houses who you could consider
like a good person,
right? Maybe maybe as fan because at least from the Emmy stuff,
it sounded like he was like like a good person but an aloof person
who didn't like didn't participate in the same stuff. Maybe.
I don't know. These guys just all seem to suck. Nick lastly,
she states Nick was very controlling over their online presence
and content they posted online. The three above purchases and
him controlling all the money lays the f foundation for financial
abuse which ultimately gives the discretion to the judge to again
award her more than 50% of the state. >> Let's talk about
financial abuse. If you and your spouse have agreed that your
spouse is going to work and you are going to work in the home,
meaning take care of the home, take care of the daily needs of
the children, you should still have access to your marital funds,
meaning your spouse's paycheck. If you don't, that is financial
abuse. If you have to ask your spouse for a credit card, their
credit card to get cash or buy groceries or buy clothes for your
children, that is financial abuse. If >> I still think
Rich Campbell was innocent and the girl was just jealous he was
with Mia. Esan seems not actually nice and Finn, too. Well, Rich
I don't think Rich is necessarily guilty. I just don't think
there's enough information to know there.
I I just feel like if you were going to a lot of these parties
and stuff, you probably saw a lot of these dudes cheating or
saw like indications they were cheating, right? It doesn't seem
like any of these guys were really hiding what they were doing
and they all kind of like meme and joke about it.
It
I just Yeah. You know, you know, >> you have to ask your
spouse for money to go and get your nails done or to buy yourself
a new outfit. That is financial
>> Not to mention, she accuses Nick of spending their community
funds on gambling trips, paramores like it's Kachchi and excessive
gifts. Literally, Nick is caught in 4K spending money on his
kachi and taking trips with her. >> Oh my. >> Oh
boy. >> My man is down
>> Um, I would just say you are a generous person, right?
>> I I This is This is embarrassing.
I really
I don't know how to talk about
Like it this feels embarrassing to me. Like I couldn't do this.
You know what I mean? like being the guy who's going out and
buying this so you can date somebody who's like four points higher
than you on a scale out of 10. Like I it's just embarrassing.
You got peer pressure by the rest of OTK to have an Asian girlfriend.
I just mean it's just kind of goofy.
It's just it feels goofy. It feels like
I don't know the word. It's so weak. Like you are so weak as
a person. You're so mentally weak. It's very It's very Yeah.
Pathetic is probably the word I'm actually looking for. Knockdocs,
thank you. Like, it's it is pathetic.
Like, he
and I honestly, I wouldn't be shocked if this was almost entirely
to get back at Molina, right? Not that he's even like I'm sure
he's having like a fine time, but I I feel like this is almost
certainly to be like, look, I'm I'm out here hanging out with
this person all the time. I'm not going to stream on my main
channel. I don't know. It's [__] goofy. I want to
I want to explain >> answer cost $11,000.
>> What' you say? >> That answer cost $11,000.
>> Girl, you know it didn't cost that much. Oh, man. Dude,
tell tell them it didn't cost that much. >> No, wait. Wasn't
it like 14k?
>> Why? I'm sure he's going to try to convince everybody
that it was is Catch's money because we know she come >> Well,
11 less 11K for Molina. Pack the man. If you think that's how
that works, you are out of your mind. Do you think you're the
only person who has ever thought, "Oh, or or the only person,
Do you think Nick's the only person, if that were the case, that's
ever thought, well, I'm going to spend this money so that it
doesn't so that they don't get it. It's a joke." I'm just telling
you,
I guarantee you all those kinds of gifts, they're going to be
added up. It's going to be aberant spending that is going to
get thrown entirely entirely on Nick's side of the divorce.
Right. It was a joke. Okay. All right. it was a joke or something
like that, but the credit card receipts don't lie. When it comes
to cheating, Molina denies ever cheating on Nick. She also considered
him asking her that question to be harassment cited was an abuse
of the Texas rules of civil procedure. As far as her answer,
if she believes Nick cheated, she says reference her previous
14,000 is probably like a hundred bucks to him, though it's not
that big of a s
It is that big of a s move. one 14K is not like 100 bucks to
him, right? That's like that's thinking he makes way more money
than he does.
Obviously, okay, that's that's clearly not the case. But even
then, it's like a guy who makes a regular amount of money spending
like a,000 or 2,000 bucks on a gift. Like a,000 bucks on a gift,
500 bucks on a gift. It's it's still embarrassing, right? For
somebody you've like just met is very embarrassing. is answered.
>> In my opinion, like when you're in the like early dating
stage to like get them happy to want to go out with you, that's
what I'm talking about. If like the courting if the courting
process involves you buying lavish expensive gifts, you're batting
out of your league. Okay? Just just sit down with yourself and
think about why you have to do that.
Okay? Come to terms with why you have to do that because there's
some stuff there you should be talking to your therapist about.
then goes on to say she was told by her friends and seen online
that Nick has had a romantic relationship with Nor the Explorer
and it's catchy. I wonder she she didn't put like their real
names in there because she knew like you know that these was
going to come out. Maybe she's protecting her identity even though
I would never dox them anyway. You see in Texas there's no separation
date, right? I get it. In the eyes of everyone on Twitch, Nick
and Melena are no longer together. But in the eyes of the court,
right? and some old judge. Nick is considered married until Lee's
divorce, meaning that Molina can 100% cite the reason for the
divorce being Nick cheated, which also gives her more ammunition
to make her case that she's entitled to more than 50% of the
community estate >> cheating spouse can. >> So, I
wonder if that 70% will also include Yeah. like things like gifts.
Like if you're going on trips and getting her gifts and it's
all one-sided, then obviously I'm worth I'm worth more than 50%
of the estate cuz you're spending a huge chunk of the estate
on her yourself. So that 50% is not going to be accurate. I need
70 to make sure I'm actually getting an equitable split >> and
be negatively impacted. >> Give me one second. I'm going
to roll this back a little bit. >> I would never do anyway.
You see, in Texas, there's no separation date, right? I get it.
In the eyes of everyone on Twitch, Nick and Melena are no longer
together. But in the eyes of the court, right, in some old judge,
Nick is considered married until he's divorced. Meaning that
Molina can 100% cite the reason for the divorce being Nick cheated,
which also gives her more ammunition to make her case that she's
entitled to more than 50% of the community estate. >> Cheating
spouse can be negatively impacted in the divorce. For example,
the innocent spouse might get a disproportionate share of the
marital estate. That means that they're going to get more than
the spouse who's cheating. The innocent spouse may also claim
that the cheating spouse wasted marital assets. Were they taking
their paramore? That's a girlfriend or boyfriend around the world.
>> Got them. I get it. I'm sounding like a broken record,
but this is the law, people. Now, after lay the foundation for
Nick being a cheater and the financial abuse, she reiterates
her knowing nothing about the finances when asked about her sources
of income and current employees. She holds the line saying that
they were content creators and they received money, but Nick
controlled the finances. Aiden, she has been in the dark for
all of the money.
>> Hold on one second. One second. It'll play again. Hold
on. Ah,
hello. We're >> That they have earned. Next, Molina makes
it clear that she stopped her career to support Nick when she
asked her when he asked her about her employment. She says she
was employed as an assistant. They made the decision for her
to quit being an assistant and help create content with Nick
full-time. This concludes her answers to the interrogatories.
But after all that, what is she still asking of Nick based on
everything in here? Nick is cooked, right? By cooked, I mean
he's either going to agree to pay her 70% if that's what she
asking for or he could fight it and a judge will likely award
Molina everything she's asking for. Even now, right? If you think
about all the the orders and motions she were filed previously
for support, lawyer fees, etc. He agreed to pay for them. So,
in a way, she already got what she want. I bet, you know, his
lawyer told her, "Give her what she wants. It's coming out the
community funds,
so he'll get her credit for it in the end." In the end, guys,
let me know. Do you think she should get more than 50% of the
marital
I mean, it sounds like she is straight up entitled to more than
50%. Right.
>> Oh, hold on one second. Hold on. I'm >> Sorry.
I opened my laptop up and it had the stream open. So then I was
hearing myself from across the room. Okay.
If he's blatantly cheating, the law is the law. Well, here's
the thing. They might have been like they might have understood
they had a separation, but technically having a relationship
within the confines of that separation, there is no separation
in Texas. So any separation, any relationship they get into during
that separation seems to be cheating, like adultery.
And that's the argument Henry's making for why she's likely to
get more than 50% of the assets from a financial perspective.
Wouldn't it make sense for NP to want to sell this as fast as
possible? He'll make so much more going forward streaming than
what he had before anyway. Yes, it probably would. Um I think
they're going to mediation right now. I would be shocked if he's
not ready to go to mediation. if he's not ready, he at at bare
minimum
the best the best thing for him would would be to say, "Hey,
I'll take on the expenses of like any gifts I bought, any aberant
spending, but then it'll be a 50-50 split, and I'm willing to
do that right now. You get 50% of the assets. Just let it let's
end this, right? That if he's not there yet in his head, if he's
anywhere
if he's anywhere back from there, he's a total re,
right? He would be like a complete if he's if he's not there
yet. He needs to be there. And if there's if there's worse than
that, if there's like um if she's only willing to accept, you
know, 70 or whatever, then I don't know. Good luck. Good luck,
I guess. Let's hope he's not vindictive to his own
I I've never seen anything like that. Somebody being vindictive
in the courts for their to their own detriment. Never seen anything.
I've never seen that before. Now,
there is a follow-up video. Apparently, people accused Henry
of editing documents, which is weird because to be honest, Henry
is just showing the documents he's shown before. That's very
strange to me that anybody would be accusing him of editing documents
cuz I thought maybe he would have had new documents. Doesn't
seem that way. Seems like he's just reviewing the documents that
were already there.
So, that's strange. I do want to open up his next video here.
Let's >> back in September 202. >> The video about
him editing the documents. Henry editing the documents >> after
my NMP. >> I want more. Half is plenty. I mean, I don't
even think I from my impression, Nick was never there, has never
been there. Half is plenty. And he's getting by every streamer
around him because every streamer around him is telling him,
"No, no, no. You deserve way more than half. What the [__]
you doing? Don't give her half. She doesn't She doesn't deserve
half." That has to with his brain, right? Everybody around him
like gaslighting him, telling him, "No, no, no. You don't know
that. You don't know that. You don't know that."
when the thing he needed to do was just accept that he did owe
that and move forward,
not be a [__] about it. Okay, now let's check this
out. What >> the Mena video was posted. Within 10 minutes,
right, 10 minutes, people were coming in claiming that the court
documents were fake. Specifically, the part about it's Kochi
and Nor the Explorer being named in them. Shortly after, I received
an email from a reporter who I have a history with inquiring
if I got the documents from 4chan. A friend sent me a message
asking if the post was fake that they saw in
Seph. Someone speculated that Nick was having an account with
a hidden post history for grade the thread calling the information
fake and he suggested that the comments were getting botted.
>> Dude, hold on. Hold on.
Uh, somebody somebody sent this to Nick.
Now, calling it botted might be wrong. I could definitely see
Nick going around and being like, "Hey, go post this in the Discord
and make sure people upvote it. Hey, go post this in like some
Twitter community. Make sure people upvote it, right?" Like,
I could see him doing something like that. 300 ups isn't crazy,
but if it gets like that's basically what every big influencer
does. I don't know if you guys know this, but like Destiny, all
of his tweets will go into DG chat. I do that cuz I think it
it it like uh what do you call it like confounds the algorithm.
Any algorithm on social media will take like things that take
off hard, things that ramp super hard, it'll propagate them out
because it thinks, oh, that's like possibly going viral, right?
So, if you get that big ramp early on, everybody does that. Just
100% for Nick's idiocy. Welcome back, Kenny. Haven't seen you
in a while. How's it going? So, people do this. I wouldn't be
shocked if Nick did this. If he was taking this LSF thread and
taking his comment and sending it to people saying, "Post this
somewhere for me." I doubt he'd do it on his own cuz he doesn't
want to get caught doing it, but I'm willing to bet. All right,
>> because it had 300 up votes in 30 minutes. TLDDR: Henry
got baited by an edited document that was posted on 4chan is
now using clicks. The entire part about Nor the Explorer and
his conscious is fake. They double down on it being fake and
implied that the real court document would get the Twitch handle
correctly. The person behind this account is likely one of N
one of the NMP soldiers who Nick encourages to argue with people
in outlets like Reddit and Twitter for him because
>> Hold on. Wait, that's going to be content right there.
Didn't you say you were quitting alcohol since October? Die.
I mean, when I get drunk, I do not magically become anti-Semitic.
That's just me. Die,
sir. Pollm, give me the word,
dude. He's in his Discord being like, "Guys, just go defend me.
Go defend me, please. Please." This is him and Destiny have like
a suspiciously similar way of handling this, don't they? Right.
Like they're both doing the same thing. They're both doing the
guys, why won't anybody defend me? They can't even get the truth
out there. Like I Everybody just Everybody's just willing to
lie about me. Why won't anyone defend me? Why Why isn't anybody
saying my side on
I guess I have to defend myself cuz nobody else will defend me
or him. Because of this, I will show you guys proof that the
court documents were real all along. I'll show you how to request
them yourself. You'll actually see Molina's full responses to
all of Nick's interrogatories along with a letter that his lawyer
wrote to her lawyer regarding her lack of information provided
in her
>> Once I started covering Nick and Molina's divorce, remember
Nick filed a motion to seal it. Molina respond stated that his
request to seal a case was just another way to silence her while
he continued to make content evidencing his spending and flaunting
his new paramore. It's Kachchi. It's safe to say that Molina
wanted all of her court docs to be public. >> Wait, hold
on.
>> His new paramore, it's Kachchi. It's safe to say that
Molina wanted all of her court docs to be public to begin with,
but she ultimately agreed to seal the records instead of fighting
for them to be public in court. And now the NMP soldiers have
attempted to silence me for pointing out Molina accused Nick
of having a romantic relationship with Nora. And it's catchy.
The real reason I think Nick wants these court documents to be
ruled as fake is because he's worried that it's Kachi or Nor
the Explorer will actually end up being deposed andor have to
testify should his divorce go to trial. >> If you're cheating
with someone you're >> Well, the the other thing is
I don't Would you trust it's Kachchi with Nick being like this
this heavy this like um
when he's big sing like this? Would you even want her to pose?
Like obviously I feel like she'd lie. She's got every monetary
incentive to just lie, right? Like she knows Nick's not going
to tell the truth. The real thing I think they're scared about
is is there a third party that can speak to them doing something
in the background?
That's that's what I really think the concern is is Nick's Nick's
going to be on the defense. He's going to be trying to help everybody
cuz there's probably somebody at one of these parties, one of
these things they've gone to that's seen them making out somewhere,
that's seen them go sneak off to a bedroom together.
That's probably what he's concerned about in my opinion. That
would be a way bigger risk is not Kachi herself testifying or
being deposed, but Molina finding out that there's somebody else
who if they were deposed, they would be way less incentivized
to lie. Like that's a huge liability for Nick.
>> Mistress can end up in court. And here's how. Your mistress
is going to be called on into a deposition to be asked questions
sitting in the same room with the wife and the husband and the
two lawyers. They want to calculate every dollar that was spent
on the mistress. And the wife wants half of that. But there's
an additional bonus for the wife in terms of revenge. She gets
to see the husband and the mistress in the same room where the
mistress is humiliated and the husband is humiliated. >> So,
how did I get Nick's 16 >> Dude, Henry just pulling random
Tik Toks in. Now, you love to see it. >> Page filing. First,
you have to go to the Travis County website, enter the proper
information, and request them. It's literally that simple. Then
if you do it correctly, they'll send you an email saying, "Hey,
we got your request. Thank you for the request and next thing
you know, you will get an email." Now, the email will say, "Hey,
hello, dude." Is so apparently people are just going around.
We've seen this happen with any court case we follow with a big
influencer, right? People are just
you're lying. It's like, dude, it's right there. It's like out
in the open. It's public. I'm not lying. It's just it's all right
there. But there are still people who despite the fact that you
could have requested these publicly. I don't know if you can
now,
but despite the fact that you could request these publicly, they'll
still tell you you're >> Oh, we got your request. You need
to pay. In this instance, it was $10.90 for the 106 page filing
with a link for payment. And if you do it correctly within it
looks to be like a day they actually got back to me. You will
have your court documents. So let's get into the court document
itself. See this was filed on July 9th by Nick's attorney. This
is his motion to compel Melena to basically provide information.
Now this was also >> I'm guessing on point 11 it's going
to ask about it. It might um Oh, point 11. Is that going to talk
about the paramors or something? Point 11 is going to be asking
about like other relationships, right? And then because it's
Melena's response that says, "No, no, no. I'm convinced he was
cheating with like these two people >> doing the video
and we don't have to go through all of it, but we're specifically
wanting to focus on exhibits G
and F. These are Melena's F is Molina's response
and G is Nick's response to her lack of response." So, we're
going to go to page 89 of 106. And we This will bring us to exhibit
F. Now, as you see, I called this the money shot. And I did redact
some information. It's mostly his lawyer's
contact information. And this is the exhibit that Nick was referencing.
This is Melena's objections and answers to respondents written
interrogatories. Now, written interrogatories are just questions
that he asked her to answer. This is complete with her signature.
Looks like she submitted this on June 20th to Nick. Now, if you
look at the bottom, you'll see page one of 15. And we'll just
keep going. We don't have to. This is all redacted. This is obviously
her lawyer's information. And we can just get to the questions.
Now, this is page objections and instructions. Objection to the
instructions. So, basically, she generally objected to everything.
And you can pause it if you really want to read it. That's going
to be >> prag I do not believe this is public anymore.
In fact, I don't know if the older documents are left up since
they're from before the seal, but the rest of the case was sealed.
It's possible they decided to seal the whole thing, so it's no
longer showing on the website. You might not be able to like
request these anymore. That could be a part of the strategy is
if if you seal everything, then you can say things from before
are lies, right? There's no way to independently verify, but
I don't know. It might be that anything from before that date
might be public going forward, right?
So, we'll we'll see. I'm not totally sure how that works, actually.
As we keep going on, question number one, this is about money.
All of for the most part, most of the questions are going to
be about money. It's all good. Don't worry about it. Um, but
we are here to get to is Catch's part. We know that these are
the companies she named from the video. This is page 450. >> Okay,
real quick. Before we get to that part, guys, don't forget that
if you like the content, go ahead, follow on every platform.
Follow on Kick. Follow on Twitter. Follow on Twitch. On Twitch
and Twitter, it's JSLK with an underscore. on kick. It's JSTLK.
Join the Discord. discord.gg/jstlk.
And if you really like the content, go ahead. You can throw a
couple bucks my way. You add more time to the stream. All right.
You can donate a couple different ways. You can use the TTS links.
Okay? There's Streamlabs. There's Kickbot. Let me throw this
over in the Twitch chat for you guys. All right. You can sub
on any platform. Okay? You can sub on Twitch. You can sub on
Kick. You can give me Twitch primers. All right. Love the primers
over on Twitch. Thank you very much for all of those. You can
also sub on kick if you have to choose one. If you're going to
pay either way, if you have to choose one, the kick is always
nice because kick is a 955 split. Goes directly into my bank
account. All right,
last but not least, guys, if you still want to if you want to
support monetarily, you don't care about adding time to the stream,
there's the Patreon,
there's a bunch of different tiers. There's lots of additional
content. There's lots of there's there's perks in the Discord.
Okay, if you're not one of the Discord users, probably not that
interested in in the Patreon for those perks, but we will do,
you know, if we don't go 8 hours on a stream, if we only make
it, you know, five or six hours, we'll go do supporter stream
after that. We'll go to an other stream after that. We'll go
do extra Patreon content. Okay. Is it true Twitch pays you by
mail check? It is not. They pay me directly. They have direct
deposit information.
All right. So, yeah, guys, if you like the content, go ahead,
sub, donate, add more time to the stream. I appreciate just the
views. Okay, I appreciate the views. Appreciate everybody who's
watching. Thank you very much. Let's get on with the content.
Let's continue
going down to the It's reference. >> As we continue to
go down to prove that these court documents are indeed real,
please identify and detail all domestic international investments.
It's not much here. We continue for the trust. We We went through
all of this, guys. I promise you, you've seen it
Um, she objected to what question is this? State the division
of property. Does despite her objecting to it, she still doubled
down that hey, she wants a disproportionate share of the estate
based on it being Nick's fault. Okay, you will always have that
in there. We keep going down because we want to get to the it's
Kachchi question. Here's all the bank accounts and property that
she's know that they own. As we keep going down, these are the
companies that she previously named earlier in the court document.
We're at page seven. Let's keep going down. This is, I believe,
what is this? The debt that they own. Oh, for each sum of money
owed by the community estate, separate estate >> specifically
aware >> um these Chase credit cards and leases. But we're
not here for that. We're here for the it's Kachi and
nor the Explorer question. Now, before we get there though, right,
his lawyer did ask about the $500
purchases
and she named three people. Now, look guys, I have no dog in
this fight. You can say um team Elena as much as you want, but
I do think this is sad that you have to ask your millionaire
husband if you could buy something as small as an iPad. >> Wait,
hold on, hold on, wait, wait, wait. What was the question? I
need to I need to see this. If you have made any gifts or transfers
of funds, money of property or property rights in excess of a
value of $500
in the aggregate to any person unrelated to you by blood or marriage
since January 1st, 2022, and for each gift or transfer date,
the identity and location of each gift, the date, nature of the
gift or transfer, and the value of the gift or item
>> Before we get, his lawyer did ask about the $500
purchases
>> and purchases in excess of $500.
So, person one, person two, person three. So, somebody's 30th
birthday. They've got an $1,800 gift
on his credit card. $3150
for on April 1st, 2025 as a belated birthday present. And then
Christmas gift was an iPad. Okay. Okay. >> Three people
in her family. Look guys, I have no dog in this fight. You could
say, um, >> these are definitely streamers.
These are definitely streamers. You could easily figure this
out. team Elena as much as you want, but I do think this is sad
that you have to ask your millionaire husband if you could buy
something as small as an iPad. He has to approve it because guess
what? The credit card is held in his name and she was just likely
a user on the credit card. Now,
I mean,
uh, held in Nicholas's, it doesn't mean I don't know if she wouldn't
have had her own card with her like her own name on it. I don't
think this is like a terribly weird split. You would probably
want to join an account where where this stuff could be done
though, right? So she could have some sort of independence. It
is a little weird that she has no independence at all. >> Here
we go. Question 11. If you believe Nicholas is at fault for the
breakup of the marriage, state the nature of the fault in which
you allege the breakup occurred. We scroll down to her answer.
She doubles down. I do believe Nicholas is at fault for the breakup
of the marriage on her about June 20.
Is it crazy to expect a conversation before iPads are being bought
for
Uh, not in a normal relationship, right?
But possibly in this one, right? If it's one of their close friends
and there's an approximate value of gift that you give within
the circle like the OTK streamers, it might be that like if I'm
buying a gift for an OTK streamer, one of the OTK streamers friends,
one of the like OTV streamers, somebody in this like Twitch aristocracy,
I'm probably not spending less than $1,000. Maybe not even less
than $200 or $3,000,
right? That might just be expected. So again, it depends. I do
think there's there's probably a lot of reason to believe that
this stuff wouldn't need permission every time. I would expect
you'd reference it, right? Hey, just so you know, I'm buying
like this gift. Just so you know, I'm saying it's from both of
us. I would expect that's the conversation that happens. >> Fourth,
we got the Spain trip. We have the other woman in his phone allegedly.
I mean, these are all allegations. At the end of the day, I'm
sure Mr. Arthur is going to
object. Now remember he continues to spend these gifts. We keep
going. Remember this question. This is question number 11 because
this gets referenced. So we go down to question 15. We can keep
scrolling. Like I said, if you want to read it, pause it. Go
forward. She did not commit any family violence.
Uh she did not cheat. Now we get to the iskoti question, right?
If you allege that your spouse has engaged in intimate intercourse
uh with someone else other than yourself during this marriage,
identify the facts which you're specifically aware of. So you
keep scrolling down. Scroll down some more. Scroll down some
more. Scroll down some more. And there goes your answer. This
is the same answer that they're saying is fake. Please see response
to number 11. I've been told by my friends and I have seen online
that Nicholas has had a romantic relationship with Nord Explorer
and it's Kachchi. Now I get it. Let's keep going. We said we
was going to get some new court documents. So, let's get to the
new. How did Nick respond to this? As we keep going down, keep
going down. What was this question right here? Um, this was what
if you're going to contend property that is separate,
who cares? I'm sure the
the pro the separate property will come up at some point. This
is like the thing I think is actually happening that Nick doesn't
realize is probably there's some people around Austin who have
seen the kind of that's going on and don't think Nick is based.
Don't think it's super cool that he's trying to [__]
his wife over in this divorce and cheating on her at the same
time or you know that he immediately went off to this other woman
who he's buying a bunch of lavish gifts for. And she's probably
just getting updates from those friends,
right? Nick Nick has to understand that like he can't you can't
bring Kachi to all of these events including what did she do?
Did she throw up a Roman at one of the things?
She did, right? If I remember correctly, wasn't that the whole
N bit? She like throws up a Roman at this like dude and she's
like super drunk making an ass of herself.
I'm sorry you Nobody can really not see it. Everybody sees it.
Everybody sees what you're doing.
>> At this point in time, discovery is still going. >> Uh
she seiled
is what knock says. Yeah, Knockox. We call that throwing up a
Roman here. >> I'm unable to substantially answer the question.
During the marriage, Nick and I made content for which we were
paid. And she contends that he always controlled the finances
and she's been in the dark.
We keep going. We keep going. We keep going. Let's get to his
responses, right? Cuz we we've seen all this. If you've seen
the original video, you've seen all this. She was an assistant.
Stop being an assistant to help Nick make content. As we keep
going, keep going. Now, we get to exhibit G, right? We see the
end of page 15. How did Nick's response? Okay, so June 24th,
within four days, he responded
saying, "Hey, we're in seat of Miss Palone's
responses dated June 20th, and we write to address the following
deficiencies." Deficiencies as it's missing evidence.
All right. Now, we keep going down. I'm just not I'm not even
going to read it, guys. You can you can go through it. You can
see it. Uh the highlighted stuff, monthly expenses. She did not
provide any documents related to her monthly expenses.
save and accept her lease. Please supplement the response because
she was looking for temporary support which was agreed upon by
Nick. You keep going down. I guess there was a 2024 tax return
that Nick wanted. I believe not all at this point all financial
records from both sides should be shared as they're likely in
separation or preparing for their trial date in January. But
I think they're going to settle. Um as we keep going, keep going,
keep going.
Um, I guess he wanted to know all of her Instagram
Red Reddit accounts, Snapchat accounts. It is our understanding
that Miss Palone maintains profile on various social media platforms,
including but not limited to Instagram, Twitter, Dude, I wish
I wish she'd ask for the same in return. Hey, I want everything
he's got and please don't leave anything out and we could just
see which of those Reddit accounts is actually him. All right,
cuz I'm looking at this LSF thread and the comments there and
I'm wondering, you know, maybe Nick was the guy. Maybe Nick is
the guy just posting on his own behalf in the LSF threads. Okay,
maybe he is. >> X, Twitch, Facebook, please supplements
the responses. Now, this is an interesting question because I
imagine just like Nick has accounts on Reddit, Twitter, X, all
that good stuff. She likely has the same. Um, but that's an assumption.
Um, written out interrogatory deficiency. Hey, we need the answer
to the Norway question about the Norway property that they may
or may not own. And you keep going. Uh CC Nick. All right. Now,
what I really want to address is the soldiers. So, apparently
Nick has a soldier rank within his community where people say,
"Hey, I got the soldier rank. I got to give people getting slack.
Soldiers are exempt from god knows what. This is a r >> bro.
I should do this. I should I listen. If you post under uh if
you post under the blastoff tweet, you're going to be immune
from like slow mode in the Discord. you're going to be immune
from a whole bunch in the Discord, but I need you guys to go
like the blastoff tweet, okay? Retweet the blastoff tweet, post
links under the blastoff tweet to the
All right, this is actually so smart, guys. If you defend me
online, if you defend me in a whole bunch of places, then I'll
give you a role that like makes you a higher tier in the community.
Yes, Nick. Yes.
Yes.
So smart. So smart. Thank you.
What a fantastic idea >> that he encourages people to go
on play. >> Okay, Trump. Yeah, the whole idea is listen,
I could just say, hey, it really helps the stream if you guys
go like this tweet with your Twitter account. But people are
too lazy. They need something from me, right? I'm telling you
they need something. It's not like it's hard to go like this.
I tell you it helps the stream. That doesn't matter, does it?
No, it doesn't. What would matter is if I, you know, didn't time
you out from the Discord. If I did, that's what would matter.
Okay. And I can see it. I see it. Nick is so smart. >> Places
like X to argue on his behalf. You literally >> incredibly
gay. Listen, it's not like it's a witty tweet. It's just a blastoff
tweet. Okay, just the blastoff tweet. >> Have one of his
followers telling people to Die. Someone pointed out that Nick
is recruiting people to fight haters on Twitter and Reddit and
4chan. I just saw Twitter, not Discord. If I interrupted things,
sorry. This is the person who is telling people to die on Discord.
Okay. And if you're fighting on Nick's behalf, you are considered
to be in the trenches. Soldiers, keep up the good work. As you
keep scrolling down, you know, look, some people don't even like
the soldiers there. But you have other people saying, "Hey, can
you change the soldier tag? It seems the same as the streamer
color." And someone saying, "Look, I hate soldiers more than
skitsos as you keep one of his top soldiers right here with their
with their rank." People are literally showing proof that, hey,
on 10:31,
give me a soldier roll because I upvoted. Why isn't this under
every comment section in LSF? >> I mean, I think he probably
posted it. It's the same name. Uh-oh. Henry not beating the illiterate
allegations right now. Godamn. >> About other streamers,
but for some reason, it's under this one about Nick. Why do we
care what NMP has to say? This This is the culture that he's
creating. Hey, how did you when did you get your soldier roll?
The fourth of July incident. Like what? I think in July. Obviously,
these soldier rolls is not something you you know you >> I
think it's the funny thing about this is like you can convince
people to do stuff like this, but once you if you're convincing
them to lie, that's way different, right? Like there's a big
difference between like, hey, if you agree with this, go up vote
this versus like I'm going to incentivize you to go like lie
on my behalf or just like emotionally argue on my behalf. There's
like something different there, right?
I say it's like a good idea or whatever. Obviously, I don't like
that people like Tetoone and Nick do this. Obviously,
you choose. You earn it by showing proof that you're defending
Nick and his honor online. And here for those who don't remember,
this is the July 4th incident. Let's play it out. >> Like
there are like 13 confirmed people dead and like 12 campers are
lost right now from a summer camp nearby.
>> Is it children?
>> Yeah. Let me look at this. >> Uh I don't know
about anything about this whole soldier role. What are the odds
that it's just a meme within his >> A meme where they say
like you could say it's a meme, but that would just be like uh
what do you call it? It just be like irony posting basically.
Like they're literally they're literally actively doing the thing
that is like you could meme about being a but then if you if
the meme is we all go around and like actually put anti-semitic
memes and responses to all the on Twitter then you're not really
memeing about being you're just actually being a right.
It's like the meme is there soldiers for him but the if the meme
is they're just going and like lying in comments on his behalf
then they're actually just doing the thing. So, you could say
it's a meme, but it's not really a meme if that's actually all
you do is you just go around and like defend him anywhere regardless
of how guilty he is in any given situation. The real Dr. Cube,
you're just not paying attention. It's okay. I'm probably not
going to explain it. It was literally explained in the video.
Literally, just go back and listen again. Like, I sorry, I'll
explain it real quick. People literally post, "Hey, I did a post
defending you. Give me soldier roll. Mods, give me soldier roll.
Here's my post defending Nick on Twitter on LSF."
Yeah, I was literally shown like four different examples. Snick.
Okay.
They don't have much left for anyways. It's okay. >> Wait,
they have their whole lives ahead of them. >> What? Their
whole lives, Bri.
Every when they're older, every job is going to be AI. Everything
they learn is on Chad GBT. There is no future.
>> Wow. Well, apparently if you go online and you defend
that, then you too could probably get your soldier rank. Guys,
I've been doing this a long time and even going back to me first
being known for XQC, I've never posted any fake court documents.
Unfortunately, Nick is freaking joined from >> Henry's
Henry's unimpeachable record remains unimpeachable. Okay, he's
literally never up
at JTO. I defended you. That's cool. You should never defend
me if you think I'm actually wrong in a situation, though. Okay,
I'm never I and and if I tell you in the future that like I feel
like I'm not getting support and nobody's defending me and you
think I'm wrong, you still shouldn't defend me, okay? You shouldn't
go and like lie on my behalf. It's
it looks goofy. Makes this community, if this community ever
had a chance, you know, if there was some big controversy and
it required like us getting through it with lies, then maybe
the community doesn't deserve to exist. possibly >> commented
on the divorce. So, I doubt he'll come out and say that they're
fake. But the documents are 100%
real. They always has. They always were. But you have this NMP
soldiers trying to spread misinformation to my >> No, Bill
Dr. Cube, you're fine. You're fine. It's all good. >> Character
even attack my integrity. More court docs are on the way. I have
several cases I've yet to get to cover, but let me know what
you think in the comments section. I'll see you next video. peace.
Hold on a second. Some people are arguing over how did these
two meet? How did its Kachi
How did it It's Kachi and NMP lol meet. Let me see if I can just
look that up and see. Hold on. I'm waiting to see if there's
like a a total like a story here. >> Clear. What is this?
>> Yeah. Yeah, it sounds all right. So, it's fine. So,
it's not that big of a
Um, so
from the get-go,
I wasn't 100% sure cuz Okay, when I first met Nick, it was top
streamer, right?
HOLD ON. REALLY?
OTK's next top
It's Kachi. Can we see her entry?
Becoming OTK's top streamer.
VOD Archive. OTK's next top streamer.
Wait, wait, wait.
How old is this?
This is last year VOD archive.
Is she reacting to her own thing? >> I think we going to
have >> I can't even focus on the video. >> Hold
on. I'm looking. I'm looking. I'm just going to try to see it.
>> So weird. >> Oh, here we go. >> I feel bad
for his reaction right now. >> I just feel >> Where
is she? Oh, boy. >> He does. He really does. >> They
got a lot in common. They're both white and they're both want
to be >> I don't know if she's on this one. Hold on. Let's
see if we just find a YouTube. Here we go. Here we go.
This is the same VOD. Let me go see if we can find
>> Nick's favorite. It's catchy. Yo, so
>> Dude, there's no way it's as transparent as this, right?
There's no shot it's this transparent that it's like,
yeah, she was like a small streamer who entered this contest
and I was like, hey, I can make you a big streamer. What's the
path to you becoming a big streamer? My my dick is the path to
you becoming a massive streamer. Actually,
>> you [__] you. >> Oh my gosh. Am I
live? Can you hear me? Can you see me?
>> Wait, why was it right? Why Why would one of them say
that and just give it away? Nick's favorite. It's catchy.
Isn't that That's [__] up. Was that Tone or was that
Asmin Gold? I think that was Tekone. Techone was throwing shots.
No wonder No wonder Nick threw out.
Hold on. Nick's fave.
>> Nick's favorite streamer.
>> No way. >> Is Is she allowed to talk? >> Oh,
hold on. That's a different one. Hopefully Nick wasn't in DMs
with that one, too. >> Nick's favorite. It's catchy. Yo,
so good to see you. [__] you. >> Oh my god.
>> It's a joke. He hated her at first. Okay. Techone does
seem to be saying that a couple times. Nick's favorite. Nick's
favorite. >> Am I live? Can you hear me? Can you see >> Yes,
you're live right now.
It's touching. >> Would y'all give me a leaf? >> What
do you mean? Wait, what do you mean I'm not your favorite? Excuse
me?
>> You're like, "No, no, she's not my favorite." WHAT DO
YOU MEAN BY THAT? >> WHO YOU ARE? YOU'RE NOT MY FAVORITE.
>> WHAT DO YOU MEAN? WHAT DO YOU mean you don't know who
I am? I talked to you on stream like two days ago. You pulled
up MY CHAT >> AND EARLIER TODAY we were talking >> This
is kind of cringe. Yeah, it's OTK. I don't know if you guys realize
this. All of the OTK is incredibly cringe all the time. Basically
all of it except the drama stuff >> about me. I was like,
"What the [__]
>> Why are you watching me? I'm not watching you. What
are you doing? >> This feels very familiar." >> No,
you you knew that I had 300 average viewers for my second stream.
How did you know that? >> Because I'm a stats guy. I know
everything. I know everyone's view count. That's what I do. It's
how I make my million.
No. No. Nick. No. Nick, you have to stop. Nick, stop talking
to >> everyone. So, including mine. So, you were looking
at my my stats >> because you're an enigma. It doesn't
make sense, dude. No way.
>> What do you mean I'm an enigma? What does that even
mean? you you were you were at zero
>> and you still this competition and you got 2.4K viewers
from zero and now every time you go live you have more viewers
than my friend Mr. Arthur who's been streaming for 3 years. You
more viewers than Russell. So true. So true. Everybody picked
it up immediately. Enigma's never age.
Listen, we should just be thankful that this time when Nick decided
on a new partner, they weren't 15. Okay? That's what we should
really be thanking our lucky stars for.
>> Hey, so real quick, real quick question. How much money
did you make on PayPal?
>> I'd rather not say.
>> Okay. Was it over $1,000?
>> I'd rather not say. I'm not I'm not going to give a
number. >> Okay. All right. That's fine. It is what it
is. >> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. It is what it is. So, yeah. Hello.
>> Yeah. So, so what what made you decide to uh go live
for one time to join Top Streamer? Who's your favorite streamer
so far?
>> Okay. I mean, I'm going to talk more about it in my
audition, so I'm not going to spoil anything, but I feel like
I've been pretty lucky with these three because you guys are
the ones I watched. >> Wait, does she have an or is this
to go to the next round? Check this out. What is this?
>> Yeah. All in all, it was like 30 hours to get >> Nick
meets it for the first time. >> Got here. And now I'm here.
I have like 4 hours of sleep, so I apologize in advance for anything
I say or do. >> Okay. Well, very good. >> 3 months
later. >> Get ready to apologize again.
>> It's casual. Everybody go ahead and have a seat. >> Oh,
this is going to be awkward. >> Very good. Very, very,
very good. >> She's going to like hug him or something,
isn't she? Oh, it's so obvious right off the bat. It's so obvious
right off the bat. He is like, "Please don't do anything that
outs this. Please don't do anything that outs this. Please don't
do anything that outs >> Uh, okay. Today is going to be
a great show. I cannot wait, guys. Uh, this is something that
>> Wait, wait, wait. >> I didn't miss something right
on the first two seconds of it. >> All in all, it was like
30 hours to get here and I'm here. >> 30 hours to get here.
No. >> Very, very, very good. >> Nervous when she
walks over. >> This is going to be a great show. I cannot
wait, guys. >> Uh, this is something that is uh this is
a show that
uh we've been wanting to do for a really long time. I think it
was one of the first uh things that came up in our meetings was
uh trying to do a show like this about four years ago actually.
Actually about >> Why is
like bro the financial the financial damage to me from this is
going to be excruciating. I'm I'm so I'm so financially right
now. I'm so financially screwed. Longer clip. Hold on. Yeah.
What was going on? >> Going to try to do my best. Uh, what
do you think is going to be the >> Wait, why is he already
doing this? I have to already go back. Why is he already doing
it?
>> Hello. Yeah, >> I'm sorry. He's already doing
it. >> Just had to hit all the soft the soft spots there.
Thank you, Sand.
>> Wait, what? What?
>> Here we have some judges here. It's going to be fantastic.
And I absolutely cannot wait. Go ahead and have a seat and we
are going to bring our next guest out for today. Ladies and gentlemen,
he is the chicken gladiator. Used to be a really good hockey
player. Used to be in a relationship. NFP lol.
>> Hello. Yeah, great intro. >> That's funny. >> Got
to hit all the soft the soft spots there. Thank you, Sandman.
>> Our next contestant for today comes all the way from
down under. T10. >> I feel like this Don't I see this girl
in a ton of OTK stuff? Isn't this girl like popular now? >> Very
good. Very good. Very good. Very good. Our next guest is a big
man. He's not the biggest man that we've seen from Norway, but
he is a big big man. >> A rock. >> It's Canute. Wait,
it's not Canute. Wait, what? It's like young Canoot.
>> Oh, Andy's drunk.
>> Okay, hold on. Hold on. >> Some people hate her.
Some people love to hate her. It's Cashi.
>> Yeah, some of you guys hate me. Some of you love me,
but I'm here anyway.
For some reason, I'm here. But hi.
>> Who watches this? Sincerely, I have no idea. Like, sincerely,
I have no clue who watches this. I suspect it's a lot of people.
Just people trying to jerk off. Okay, that's that's what's going
on mostly.
Living vicariously through one of the OTK people, whichever one
is ethnically closest to you. >> How do you feel about
uh how do you feel about the the show today? What do you How
do you think it's going to go today? >> I have no idea.
This is my first time doing improv in my whole life. So, it's
going to be on the internet forever. So, that's amazing for me.
>> Dude, why is he already like I feel like the joke is
that people already know they're together at this point,
right? Am I Am I
That's the only explanation. Give me another explanation
then. Oh, I'm really I'm really concerned that this is going
to go sideways right now.
She's drunk as. Yes, but why is that concerning to Nick? I don't
know what part of the timeline we're in. This is OTK's top streamer.
So, here's her auditioning for OTK's top streamer back here September
5th, 2024. This is in uh October of 2024. This is a month later.
One month later, she's at this event. All right. So, after she
had these interactions here, Nick is already Dude, I think I
think it's entirely possible Nick is like already kind of concerned
here. I feel like there's a decent chance he's in DMs already
at this point. If I I'm just schizo reading, okay, he feels like
there's a very good chance that he's already in DMs here.
And then a month later,
he's like just hoping he's just praying nothing gets brought
up. >> And I am regretting everything, every decision I've
made in my life. But it's too late. I'm here anyway, so I'm going
to try to do my best. >> Uh what do you think is going
to be >> I'll be real. She doesn't seem that drunk.
Why? Why do people think she's that drunk? Did she stumble on
her way >> Some people love to hate her. It's Ki.
>> Hi, Ki here. >> Yeah, some of you guys hate me,
some of you love me, but I'm here anyway
>> for some reason. >> She's not even slurring that
badly. >> Cash, how do you feel about uh how do you feel
about the the show today? What do you think uh how do you think
it's going to go today? >> I have no
>> uh what do you think is going to be the the biggest
uh challenge for you today? The biggest the biggest hurdle? Honestly,
my jet lag because I came from the Philippines.
So, I traveled 30 hours and also I'm gonna I'm gonna call out
I'm gonna call out the airline right now. Okay. My layover was
supposed to be 5 hours. It became 10 hours, but you know why?
Technical difficulties.
So, my plane was crashed. >> That was >> Wow. That's
a That's a zinger. That's a That's awesome.
What's the deal with airline travel, guys? Hey guys, she's just
doing that version, right? She's doing the the Filipino version
of this. Guys, what's the deal with airline travel?
You ever had You ever been on an airplane and things are delayed?
Anybody ever Anybody heard about this plane delays? Sometimes
planes are
>> Actually, my uh my ex was on that plane. It's catchy.
Everybody go ahead and have a seat.
>> Very good. Very very very good. Uh, okay. Today's gonna
be a great show. I cannot wait, guys. Uh, this is something that
is uh this is a show that
uh we've been wanting to do for a really long time. I think it
was one of the first. >> Here comes the hot micer. No,
no, no. >> It's not a >> Hold on one second.
Okay, let's see. NMP reveals the date stream was initially supposed
to be with Katchi.
So, this is 11 months ago. He was supposed to have a date stream
with Katchi. Who is What is this? >> Did you
you
want to hear something? >> November 2026.
>> did you tell him about what the date stream was originally
supposed to be?
>> No. Catchy. It was supposed to be with you, but Arthur
was out of town.
>> Yeah, I know. It's so [__] funny, but whatever.
Oh my god. Not even Homelander could get this out of me. Why
does this make you laugh so hard? Why does it make you laugh
so hard? Huh? Because like I'm such a
>> You are,
>> bro. What?
Bro, huh? So, hold on. There's a comment under here that is,
"Imagine your entire career as a 33-year-old man is to walk around
with your online role-play girlfriend and another woman faking
a love triangle while saying creepy semi-scripted lines for 5
hours a day to entertain 15-year-old terminally online parasocial
kids and 27-year-old virgins. And yet you're paid six figures
a month to do it. I would be depressed as but. But at least I
could wipe away my tears with $100 bills. Acting for 5 hours
a day, 5 hours. You'd be lucky.
This was not a secret. I don't think
I still remember it when it was first supposed to happen like
early October. Arthur was still there with Kachi, but Nick pushed
it back and ran out of time. Okay. I I don't know what the implication
is yet. I'm still getting my bearings on this. Okay. What did
What did the real Dr. cube say? What did you just link? >> What's
the deal with airplane food? >> Okay. Okay. All right.
Yes. Jerry Seinfeld. That was That was the joke. Yep.
I'm going to keep listening here. >> She won't stop whispering
to me.
>> I can hear you. I'm trying to tell you. Stop whispering
>> Really long time. I think it was one of the first >> Here
comes the hot micer. No. No. No. >> It's not a
Wait, why is that? Hold on.
What got edited out there?
Wait. What got edited out? What did she say? Now I need to see
this uncut. What is the What is the whisper there that's getting
cut out? You all see that, right? They're saying hot micer. >> There's
a cut. >> There comes the hot mic. >> There's a cut.
What was cut? What was cut here? I feel like that is actually
important. Stays for 60 days. Full vaude. It'll be gone.
How do we find this? Hold on. Hold on. OTK top streamer improv.
I need one of these skits. I need one of these skits right now.
>> The improv challenge right here.
>> I don't know if >> Give me a second. >> This
might be shocking. >> The transcripts. >> Uh, I'm
actually a British. Everyone here is from all like Australian
different countries. >> I'm actually a a British actor.
>> Hot mic. >> Is that loud enough?
>> Hot mic in the back. Hey, in the back. Stop talking.
>> Do we have a audio issue? >> Hold on. >> Before
or is there some confidence? >> Hold on. Let me see. >> I'
I'd say there's some confidence. Yeah. But I think improv is
also pretty scary for anyone. So yeah, it's it's it's also gone.
So
>> It is now. Yeah, I guess so. >> Here comes the
hot micer. No, no, no. >> It's not a
She won't stop whispering to >> Okay, but that's that's
before whatever was happening. What is she whispering before
this? years ago. So, I think the is the Yeah, we started DK four
years ago. So, that's pretty cool. Yeah, pretty cool. Uh, so
we're very excited about this today and we are going to go over
how the games are going to work. >> So, guys, when you
hear this buzzer
>> here we go. >> Oh, is that loud enough? >> So,
it's him going, "They hear you. Stop. Stop saying this." And
they didn't hear her. Or at least I don't hear her.
>> Oh, is that loud enough?
When you hear this, buzzer. Buzzer.
>> Oh, is that >> I'm sorry.
Probably just whispering so it's distracting. I don't know. I
don't know, man. That's hard to say right there.
>> I don't know.
Here we go. Not this one. This one. This >> The hot micer.
No, no, no. >> She won't stop listening. >> No, no,
no. >> She won't stop whispering. >> Go ahead and
uh just give us something in chat. We'll give him a character
to play and I'll pick I'll pick something out of chat for you.
>> I'm scared. Oh, you should be best. Uh, give us your
best James Bond.
What do you think? >> It's easier. >> What do you
think of >> Cuz you're Hold on. >> Give us your best.
Uh, give us your best James Bond. >> It's right there.
That's That's all we pick up. >> What do you think of James
Bond?
>> What do you >> It's easy for >> What do
you think of? >> Cuz you're you've been streaming
It's easy for something you've been streaming for so long. I
don't I don't even know
>> too much in each place.
>> It's easy for you. Something it's you've been streaming
for so long.
She's just being rude. She might just be
>> very good. Very good. Very good. Very good. Very good.
Very good. >> James Earl Jones.
>> Very good. Very good. So guys, when you hear this buzzer
buzzer
>> is that loud enough? Hot mic. >> Is that loud
enough? >> They can't hear me picking my nose. >> Here
comes the hot micer. No, no, no. >> It's not a
She won't stop whispering to
>> Just think people watch this. I know people watch this.
It's